former constitutional rights lawyer
Glenn Greenwald contends that the United
States has a two-tiered judicial system
one for the haves and one for the
have-nots this is a little over an hour
so thank you thank you very much and on
behalf of professor Chomsky thank you
for that very warm reception thanks very
much for for coming
this afternoon and in particular thanks
to professor Chomsky it is indescribably
gratifying to be able to write a book
and then attend an event to talk about
it with the nation's bravest and most
accomplished public intellectual and
political activists so I'm particularly
grateful to Professor Chomsky for being
here
I just want to begin by making a couple
of points that I think will frame the
discussion that we're going to have
nicely and I'm not sure what that
discussion will be because we haven't
talked about it on purpose
but there a couple points that I
anticipate will help to highlight that I
think I'd like to just briefly describe
so the book really makes the argument
that the rule of law as we have always
understood it has been radically
degraded in a way that wasn't previously
true and the interesting thing about the
rule of law is that it's a term that has
a pretty clear meaning by consensus it's
not a particularly complex term it
essentially means nothing more than the
fact that in a society we are all bound
on equal terms by a common set of rules
and you can look to contemporary legal
scholars who define it that way you can
look more interestingly to the 1980s in
the 1990s when Western institutions like
the IMF and the World Bank began
demanding that lending country or
countries that received lending
comported with the rule of law and there
were lots of lectures issued about what
they were required to do in order to
comport with the rule of law there was a
seminal Journal article by Thomas
Carruthers in foreign affairs that
warned that countries that don't live
under the rule of law in those countries
elites can use their superior financial
power to call out political institutions
and that the critical requirement to
live under the rule of law is that
political and financially seized placing
themselves above the rule of law and are
subjected to it on equal terms to
everyone else and you go back to the
founders and as much as disagreement as
they had what you continuously find is
this emphasis not ancillary or secondary
but really central at the American
Founding in order to be legitimate and
just had to venerate the rule of law and
this was true despite the fact that
founders almost across the board
believed in the inevitability and even
desirability and virtue of vast levels
of inequality in all sorts of realms and
yet they continuously emphasized that
the only way that that inequality would
be legitimate and just is if everyone
were equal before the law now you know
anytime you make the argument or point
out that the rule of law and equality
before the law was important in the
founding you'll be met with the
objection which is obviously an accurate
one as far as it goes so I don't think
it goes very far that the founders
violently breached those principles in
all sorts of ways and that the country
did as well and that this concept of
equality under law has never been the
predominant theme to describe American
political reality and although that is
true the reason I don't think it goes
very far is because the important part
of that writing and and and that history
is that that principle has always been
affirmed as being central even at the
time that we violated it radically and
the reason that's important is because
if you affirm a principal and deviate
from it in your actions there's an
obvious aspect to your behavior that is
hypocritical but if the affirmation is
sincere and ringing and consistent then
those principles even though you're not
comporting with them become aspirational
they become guides to what progress
means how its understood and how its
achieved so even though the founders
violated that principle in all sorts of
ways the fact that they continuously
enshrined it and it was affirmed
continuously throughout the next two
centuries meant that most of the events
that we consider to be progress in
American history were driven by
the reverence for this concept that
we're all equal under the law that
equality under the law is how we
determine if we're perfecting the Union
and there's a real value in affirming
principles even if they're not perfectly
applied and what I think is radically
different about today is not that the
rule of law suddenly is is not being
applied faithfully because that's always
been true what's different about today
radically is that we no longer even
bother to affirm that principle we pay
lip service to the phrase the rule of
law but there's in terms of the
substance of what it requires you can
often and I would say more often than
not in leading opinion making elite
circles find an express renouncement or
repudiation of that principle so you
begin with the Ford pardon of Nixon
continuing through the shielding of
iran-contra criminals into the Obama
administration's decision to shield all
bush crimes of torture and illegal
warrantless eavesdropping obstruction of
justice the aggressive attack on Iraq
the decision now not to prosecute Wall
Street criminals for precipitating the
2008 crisis with systemic financial
fraud all of these acts entail very
aggressive and explicit arguments that
the most powerful political and
financial elites in our society should
not be an are not subject to the rule of
law because it's too disruptive it's too
divisive it's more important that we
look forward that we find ways to avoid
repeating the problem and so you really
see constant arguments and you did for
example during the debate over whether
or not the telecom industry should be
retro actively immunized for its role in
the illegal eavesdropping program that
the rule of law is really not that
important of a value any longer Jerry
Ford when he addressed the nation and
tried to convince it to accept the
pardon said of course I believe in the
rule of law the idea the law is no
respecter of persons but and this was
the amendment that was concocted for
that episode the law is also a respecter
of reality meaning that if it's too
direct disruptive or divisive that it's
actually in our common good not the
elite criminals but in our common good
to exempt the most powerful from the
consequences of their criminal acts and
that has really become the temp
they used in each of these instances and
that I think radically is different than
how things were in the past the other
point I want to make just to begin but
I'll turn the floor over to Professor
Chomsky is that the other difference is
that if we had a society that just
decided that we were going to be very
lenient and forgiving and merciful when
people committed crimes as I just
described we do for elites you could
have debates about whether that was an
advisable policy or approach to
criminality about whether or not that
would be produced good results or not
but if it were a quite applied across
the board at the very least it wouldn't
implicate rule of law huge there are
countries that take very lenient
approaches to criminal justice and if we
were a country that applied that same
leniency to ordinary Americans as we
apply to elites then there wouldn't be
an issue with the rule of law so for
example if you went and broke into
someone's house and and and and bash the
owner in the head with with a baseball
bat and stole their valuable belongings
and a week later or two months later got
caught by the police and you said look
officer you got me I did what you think
I did but I said it more important that
we could look to the future why that's
why focus on the past if that were
something that worked for you or for
people who sold drugs on street corners
and the like then there wouldn't be a
rule of law issue but the fact that that
applies only to to political and
financial elites and not to ordinary
Americans is the reason why there's a
rule of law problem at the very same
time that we've created this template of
elite immunity we over the past four
decades we have in the name of law and
order and tough-on-crime
built the world's largest and most
sprawling prison state one of its
harshest and most merciless systems of
punishment for ordinary Americans and
the irony that Richard Nixon was the one
who received this pardon when in the
1960s he rejuvenated his political
career by becoming the law and order
candidate following taking up the mantle
of Barry Goldwater running against the
disruption on the rest of the 1960's
demanding harsh sentences lesser parole
lesser opportunity for release from
prison the drug war was really
accelerated first under him the fact
that he built his political
career based on this harsh law-and-order
mentality and then suddenly when he got
caught committing crimes was completely
shielded from legal consequence is
really the personification of this
two-tiered justice system that I'm
writing about and then of course the war
on terror has brought all new tears of
justice where people accused of
terrorism just accused can have every
right deprived from them including the
right to life without any sort of legal
rights or legal process of any kind it's
really a new class a password there's
not even a pretense of due process it's
a persona non-grata
a sub person class where the government
can do anything without any legal
constraints at all and it's this
contrast between the shielding and
immunity that we've vested in the elite
class or more accurately that they've
vested in themselves versus the
extraordinarily unprecedented arsh and
merciless punishment system imposed on
everyone else that is the real menace to
the rule of law and that I think is the
most responsible factor for the loss of
faith in our political institutions and
the widespread accurate belief that you
see motivating the Occupy movement and
other widespread citizen rage that our
political institutions have lost all
remnants of legitimacy and can no longer
be used to effectuate change so I think
it's one of the most menacing problems
and also one of the most consequential
well let me just pick up on Glenn's last
comments and say a few things about the
rule of law happens that last night I
was reading the current journal the
current edition of the journal that went
the main journal of the American Society
for historical historical relations the
diplomatic history and the happens to be
devoted that several articles devoted to
the Nuremberg Tribunal and to what it
means how it developed and so on and the
lead article points out that one of the
most honorable and admired elements of
the American historical tradition the
legal tradition is the principle of
presumption of innocence that is a
person is presumed innocent a suspect is
presumed innocent until brought to a
fair trial and convicted with proper
procedural guarantees
that's the proudest achievement of the
American legal and ethical tradition and
of course it was recognized at Nuremberg
the British wanted just killed the Nazi
war criminals but justice Jackson the US
a-- chief prosecutor insisted that even
though these people are maybe you know
the worst criminals in history they
should be brought to trial subjected to
a fair trial
the condemned if they were proven guilty
and furthermore he added that we're
giving these defendants a poisoned
chalice and if we ever sit from it
meaning if we ever
do the things that they're accused of we
must suffer the same consequences
otherwise these proceedings are a
complete farce the core element of the
proceedings the main crime for which the
Nazi criminals were condemned and hanged
was what was called in the tribunal the
supreme international crime namely
aggression pretty clearly defined which
they said is tribunals that is the worst
of all war crimes because it encompasses
all the evil that follows
well I won't run through the way that's
been we've applied that to ourselves but
that point is correct presumption of
innocence is a very deeply rooted
principle now if American law but of
anglo-american law or it used to be that
by now it's simply totally dismissed and
with praise so for example when Osama
bin Laden was the prime suspect for 9/11
plausibly though in fact in fact of the
matter is the government has yet to
provide the kind of evidence that would
hold up in a credible court and is even
more or less conceded it doesn't have it
but undoubtedly he's the prime suspect a
couple of months ago Obama invaded
another country
commandos apprehended him and murdered
and tossed his body into the ocean
without autopsy and this was praised
this was praised as a great achievement
the great achievement of the Obama
administration a couple of months later
the concept was extended in a manner
that Glenn talks about in his book which
is a terrific book I should say that's
the case of Anwar al-awlaki a lackey an
American citizen a cleric who was
accused not of committing them to
talk about involvement in crimes but no
evidence was presented the main charge
against him was he was a fluent speaker
of English and he was the transmitting
he was presented giving offering support
for jihadi operations he was killed a
couple of weeks ago and the general
reaction was illustrated adequately in a
New York Times headline which said West
celebrates death of radical cleric well
it wasn't as death it was murder along
with another American citizen who had to
be near him and while it's true that the
and there were some who didn't join in
the celebration completely almost all of
them criticized it because he was an
American citizen which makes him a
person in theory as distinct from
non-citizens who may look like persons
but aren't that's incidentally a core
principle of current American law with
regard to undocumented aliens
interesting interpretation of the 14th
amendment but so he was an actual person
and maybe we're not supposed to murder
people suspected of inciting others to
carry out terrorist acts now again there
were some critics and the response who
went beyond that and said we should
believe in the principle of presumption
of innocence and the reaction to that
I'm actually I was one was quite
interesting most of it was the usual
shrieking which she can disregard but
some of it was interesting and in fact
the most interesting I thought was a
column by a well-known respected left
liberal commentator matthew Yglesias who
wrote that it is as he put it amazingly
naive to criticize the United States for
violation of international law or other
crimes because the International the
International order is established
precisely in order to legitimate the use
of violence by the west and by the West
he doesn't mean Norway he means by the
United States so that's the nature of
the international order it's set up to
legitimate our criminal resort to
violence and therefore it's amazingly
naive to raise criticisms about this and
soonly does not set in criticism he's
praising it he goes on to say it's silly
even to raise these questions that
happens to be directed to me and I'm
happy to accept guilt for that on that
charge but and if you look beyond and
ask just what does it mean to be a
non-person say a terror accused of
terrorism well it was a striking example
and Linton's book as he points out the
first child soldier in American history
to be brought to trial for crimes and
that was worth looking at that's Omar
Khadr there's a 15 year old boy who was
apprehended in Afghanistan and the
charge against him is that when American
soldiers were invading Afghanistan and
attacking his village he picked up a gun
at the defenders village so that makes
him a terrorist a non-person and
interesting concept of terrorism and he
was then first sent to Bagram secret
prison in Afghanistan then sent off to
Guantanamo eight years in prison
no charges after eight years in prison
he was going to be brought the truck
what's called a trial before a military
commission well to talk about that but
he pleaded guilty and a plea bargain and
was given an 8-year sentence in addition
to the eight years he spent without
charges we all know
what it means to fleed guilty in a plea
bargain after eight years in a torture
chambers he actually is a Canadian
citizen and Canada could extradited but
they are courageously refusing to step
on the toes of the master the concept of
terror and presumption of innocence is
don't find how so far gone that nobody
even bothers to discuss it it's not
maybe it was once an ancient tradition
but not for us and Glenn is quite right
that the fact that it's been violated in
the past doesn't change the fact that by
now we've changed the principle we've
abandoned even the principle I abandon
it but forcefully rejected it even to
the extent of saying the International
order is established precisely to
legitimate our violation of elementary
legal and moral principles well it goes
beyond one of them give one last example
the one of them must in there was an
article recently by a law professor who
in fact Glenn Seitz couple times of the
book Jonathan Turley who argues that
Obama may be at breaking the record for
a US president for violation of civil
rights and the law and you can make a
case one example which actually involves
the former dean of the Harvard Law
School is happens to be Obama's latest
Supreme Court up on the podium Elena
Kagan she argued a case brought by the
Justice Department against a group
called the humanitarian law project
Holder the humanitarian law project with
the support of the far-right justices
Obama won that case the charges
is one that might implicate plenty of
people here at the charge is they
provided material assistance to a group
that's on the terrorist list the
material assistance in this case was
legal advice to the PKK a group that's
on the Turkish groups on the Kurdish
groups on the US terrorist list which
means that they expanded the concept of
material assistance from say you know
providing guns or something like that to
providing the legal advice and even
advice to turn to nonviolent means
that's now criminal under US law thanks
to President Obama and it extends very
broadly in fact shortly after this
Supreme Court decision dozens of FBI
agents raided homes in Chicago and other
cities destroyed documents the usual
thing when a couple dozen FBI agents
raid your home the charge was they're
trying to find evidence that the people
they were
and finally indicted with a grand jury
are supporting a Palestinian group and a
Colombian group PFLP and FARC well maybe
they are maybe they aren't but the idea
that expressing support for groups on
the terrorist list is a crime is
material assistance that's novel and the
Justice Department position was
explained by Kagan that if you provide
legal advice to a terrorist group say
advising them to refrain from terror and
pursue non-violent means you're
legitimizing them and freeing up their
resources to carry out terrorist acts
we'll just think however oddly that can
apply as in these cases which are in
fact underway and a final comment I
which has to do with the notion of the
terrorist list that's accepted in the
United States as a legitimate category
why is it a legitimate category how is
the terrorist list established it's
established by executive Fiat I don't
have to give any justification for it
those on the terrorist list can't say I
don't belong there this is just a
decision by the executive that I don't
like you and we're going to prosecute
we're going to kill you and prosecute
anyone
now who advises you not to pursue terror
and the you look back at the history of
the terrorist list it's very striking I
mean one person who was just removed
from it two years ago is Nelson Mandela
the reason is that the African National
Congress was characterized by the Reagan
administration in 1988 right near the
end of apartheid as one of the more
notorious terrorist groups in the world
therefore the u.s. was entitled to
support the partite South Africa as it
did not only in its atrocities
internally but in its attacks on
neighboring countries which apparently
killed about a me and a half people but
that's all okay it's part of the war on
terror the fact Reagan had declared and
we have to defend the apartheid regime
against one of the more notorious
terrorist groups in the world including
Nelson Mandela by today's standards
older versus humanitarian law project
almost anyone who was involved in
anti-apartheid activity could be
regarded as a terrorist giving material
support for terrorism as I said Mandela
was just removed from the ticket from
the terrorist list two years ago he can
now come to the United States without
special dispensation there are other
equally dramatic cases take 1982
there was a state that had been on the
terrorist list Saddam Hussein's Iraq but
the Reagan administration wanted to
provide aid and assistance to Saddam so
therefore they removed Iraq from the
terrorist list and proceeded to provide
aid and assistance right through his
worst crimes denying the crimes and in
fact rather strikingly when Saddam was
tried it was for crimes that he
committed in 1982 by his standards
pretty minor crimes excluding the major
crimes
I presume because those were all
supported by the United States and in
fact even denied by the Reagan
administration well there was a gap in
the terrorist list because Iraq was
removed had we filled so it was filled
by Cuba Cuba was added to the terrorist
list partly in order to give some
justification for outlandish claims
about why we were entitled to support
murderous terrorist regimes in Central
America which left a couple hundred
thousand corpses much worse thanks to
our involvement and you had that so the
argument was well they're being
supported by Cuba so it must be a
terrorist state fabrication but that
doesn't matter in these cases however
Cuba was a pretty good choice in the
preceding years the Cuba had been the
target of more international terrorism
and probably the rest of the world
combined
a lot of it coming from right here so
therefore Cuba went into the terrorists
list and Saddam was taken off so we
could support his major crimes which
were coming well these oughta we ought
to think about why we even tolerate the
concept of a terrorist list and it's
just not questioned the government says
someone's on a terrorist list period end
of discussion
and now if you give say legal advice or
other advice to somebody that they so
designate you're a criminal and if
you're a 15 year old child who's
picking allegedly picking up a gun to
defend a village that's under attack by
US soldiers you sent off for 16 years of
prison torture and so on if that's what
the rule of law has come to it's a sad
situation sure I think we want to do we
have a few minutes and to start before
we we get to the questionnaire so I want
to make sure to leave a substantial time
but unsurprisingly what we just heard
has provoked a lot of thoughts that that
I want to make because I think so many
interesting points were just raised so
one of the interesting aspects of this
two-tier justice system and the idea
that elites can impose standards on
everyone else that they from which they
exempt themselves it's something that is
obviously mirrored in the context of
foreign relations and I think probably
was even pioneered there this idea that
the United States imposes standards on
everybody else and exempt itself is
really the template that then got
imported domestically and one of the
fascinating things to do is to go and
look at what current political leaders
say about things like war crimes
investigations and accountability when
they're in other countries doling out
sermons and lectures about what those
other countries should do so for example
President Obama who promulgated and
gifted us all with the slogan that we as
good citizens should look forward and
not backward in order to justify
shielding bush-era crimes from
accountability gave an interview last
year on television in in Indonesia and
the Obama administration has been
pushing the Indonesian government to
prosecute certain war criminals whom the
United States has long disliked and what
he told the Indonesians was it is
impossible to move forward into a
prosperous future until you've resolved
the past and Secretary of State Clinton
has visited both Kenya and Cambodia
where the United States is similarly
urging war crimes investigations to
proceed and has told them the same thing
essentially that you cannot
among the nation the community of decent
nations while you continue to harbor and
shield war criminals from accountability
and I think the time that she visited
Kenya and said that was the time that
George Bush's book was released and he
was on every major television station
being heralded as a great statesman and
of course if you read and I would really
recommend that you do I did this because
I heard professor Chomsky many years ago
talked about it and went and read at the
opening and closing statements by Robert
Jackson at the Nuremberg tribunals it's
incredibly enlightening because that was
supposed to be the expression of modern
justice and not only did Jackson point
out that aggressive war was the kingpin
crime the crime above all others but he
also said that the Nuremberg tribunals
would have value only if they were
applied not only to the defendants in
the dock but also to all the nations
here assembled meaning the United States
and his allies and yet if you were to
cite that and argue that that meant that
George Bush and Dick Cheney and Don
Rumsfeld should be prosecuted as war
criminals for the aggressive attack on
Iraq you could almost almost nothing you
could do that's more self marginalizing
than that even people sympathetic to the
idea that they should be investigated
criminally for the torture regime or for
a warrantless eavesdropping somewhat
recoil at the idea that they should be
held criminally accountable for the at
least 100,000 dead innocent Iraqis I
think because they view the act of
Congress authorizing it and the large
majorities of the American citizen each
hearing for it as something that ought
to immunize them from that and I think
shows just how lawless we become that
you can't even cite the Nuremberg
principles and argue for its
applicability in the clearest possible
case without becoming self marginalized
just a quick point about assassinations
and the like I certainly agree with
Professor Chomsky that from a moral and
ethical perspective there's zero
difference between sending a Skye robot
over another country and eradicating the
lives of non-citizens as opposed to
doing that to citizens based upon mere
suspicion or even a lack of suspicion
justice
desire to kill them but I do think
there's a practical difference that is
that there is a greater and enhanced
danger on several levels when the
government begins murdering its own
citizens for political dissidents as
opposed to citizens of other countries
on foreign soil and the difference is
this I think that you know just
legalistically the Supreme Court for
writer for better for worse right or
wrong has said that the Constitution
applies to foreigners on US soil and to
American citizens wherever they are
found in the world but more importantly
than that is that when the government
starts acting against its own citizens
it really can escalate a climate of fear
that can lead to political suppression
and I think that's one of the things
that you've really seen in the United
States one of the most striking
experiences I've had since I began
writing about politics was the first
time that I ever wrote about WikiLeaks
this was back in early 2010 and this was
before really almost nobody knew who
woke elix was at the time just before
they had released any of their news
making disclosures inside the United
States they had released several
important documents and had exposed
wrongdoing among corporations and
governments in other parts of the world
but not really in the United States and
nobody including me really knew much
about them but the Pentagon had prepared
a top-secret report they literally
classify the top secret in 2008 that
declared WikiLeaks to be an enemy of the
state and it described ways that they
could go about destroying WikiLeaks and
it's incredible because the way in which
WikiLeaks has been rendered all but
inoperable pretty much comports with the
things the Pentagon laid out in this
2008 report but in any event in this to
thought this 2008 report is top-secret
report ironically was leaked to
WikiLeaks which then published it and
the New York Times wrote about it and in
The New York Times article basically
said there's the pentagon report that's
been leaked that declares WikiLeaks an
enemy of the state and talks about ways
to destroy it and I didn't know very
much at all about WikiLeaks at the time
but I kind of assumed that any
organization that had been targeted that
way by the Pentagon was one that merited
a lot more attention and probably a lot
more encouragement and even support and
so I went and read a lot about them and
I interviewed Julian Assange for the
article that I wrote and I
I wrote about it and I posted the audio
interview and at the end I encourage
people to go and donate to WikiLeaks
because they had budgetary constraints
that were preventing them from going
public with a lot of these disclosures
it takes a lot of time and energy to
authenticate the documents one of the
things the Pentagon talked about to
destroy them was submitting fraudulent
documents to them so that when they
published it it would forever destroy
their credibility and the credibility of
future disclosures and in response to my
recommendation that people go and donate
to them and I provided a link how people
could do that electronically and online
and through PayPal
dozens of people literally told me in
many different venues in the comment
section to what I had written by email
at events like this where I talked to
people that although they agreed
wholeheartedly with what I had written
about the potential of WikiLeaks to
achieve great good that they were afraid
of donating money to WikiLeaks
especially ironically because they would
end up on some government list somewhere
or that they could even be subjected to
criminal liability under the
extraordinarily broad material support
for terrorism statutes that Professor
Chomsky just talked about and these were
not people prone to wild conspiracy
theory these were very sober Americans
who I had interaction with in the past
on other issues a lot of them were and I
could just tell from the way that they
were expressing these fears that they
were very rational people and they these
fears were well grounded and the reason
it was so amazing to me was because it
really highlighted how this
extraordinary climate of fear has been
created the United States WikiLeaks is a
group that had never been and still has
never been charged with a crime let
alone convicted of one and they couldn't
be because what they're doing is pure
First Amendment activity that the New
York Times in the Washington Post in
theory do every day which is publish a
publicized leaks that are given to them
by other people and yet these were
American citizens who were petrified of
exercising poor First Amendment rights
which is what donating money to an
organization whose political cause you
support is and they were basically
intimidated from the things we've seen
over the last ten years in terms of
lawlessness by what the government has
done from exercising these rights so you
can offer all the rights in the world on
a piece of paper or a piece of parchment
that you want you don't need to
eliminate those rights if you can
intimidate and bully the population
into refraining from exercising them and
this really occurred to me even more
when I wrote for the first time about
the extremely harsh and oppressive
conditions in which Bradley Manning was
being detained and I remember when I
first wrote about it a lot of people
wondered and I actually even wondered
myself why would the Obama
administration basically turn bradley
manning into almost a martyr and even
jeopardize its own ability to prosecute
him by subjecting him to this extremely
severe you could call it torture but at
the very least it's inhumane treatment
he was in prolonged solitary confinement
for nine months despite being convicted
of nothing his clothes were taken from
him he was stripped nude and forced to
stand naked for many of those days um
just completely punitive measures and at
some point shortly thereafter I realized
that the reason that that was done was
the same reason that the Bush
administration took people who were
completely innocent by the hundreds and
shipped them thousands of miles away to
a Caribbean island and dressed them in
orange jumpsuits and shackles and showed
the world what we had done it's a way of
signaling to the world and to would-be
challengers to American power both
domestically and internationally that we
are not constrained by law we don't have
any limits on what we can do if you're
somebody who thinks about challenging
what we can do take a look at these
pictures of people at Guantanamo who are
going to be there for as long as we want
to keep them there even if they're
innocent or if you're somebody who
discovers wrongdoing in Syria see
legality on the highest levels of our
government and you want to expose it to
the world think about and look at what
we've done to Bradley Manning or what
we're now doing to WikiLeaks without any
even pretense to legal authority and
without any constraint whatsoever it's
really the use of law as a means of
coercion which is the exact antithesis
of what it was supposed to be it's those
in power using law as a weapon to
entrench their power and to shield their
ill-gotten gains and the fact that we
can call terrorism whatever we want it
to be the fact that people who as
professor Chomsky said take up arms and
fight against American troops or
terrorists the fact that we just
indicted someone nine months ago for
quote raising funds to kill American
troops in Iraq this was an Iraqi who had
raised money to defend his own homeland
from
evading army so if you're an Iraqi and
the American army invades your country
and you take up arms against them your
terrorist Nidal Hasan who attacked a
military base of a country that has
spent 10 years for claiming we're at war
and killed soldiers about to be deployed
to war he is a terrorist as well and yet
when the United States or Israel our
allies directly target and kill
civilians by enormous numbers whether
recklessly or deliberately it would be a
radical act to describe that as
terrorism this is all designed to be
able to criminalize whomever the United
States wants namely those who challenge
it in any meaningful way and that really
is the use of law coercively to entrench
those in power rather than to equalize
the playing field the final point I want
to make and I think we can turn it over
to questions and answers is Professor
Chomsky referenced this post by Matt
Iglesias who is a byproduct of this
school near near where we're talking and
he also works for the center of American
Center for American Progress which is
basically an organization run by John
Podesta the former Clinton White House
official that was founded in essence to
justify and defend whatever the Obama
White House does with some exceptions
here and there if you search hard enough
but basically that's its function and
the fact that people who write for them
do things and say things to mitigate or
defend things like assassinating an
American citizen with no due process
probably the most radical act that you
can think of really underscores an
important point about the way the Obama
legacy is being defined in the way that
lawlessness has become normalized so if
you know three years ago and I know I
say this is somebody who was doing it if
you were to go to an event like this and
fill the room with 50% Republicans and
50% Democrats and you were to talk about
and condemn things like wild assertions
of executive authority the idea that the
president can act against anyone he
wants with no constraints whatsoever
including killing him that he can do so
in total secrecy and with no
transparency or checks and of course
after we killed Anwar Awlaki two weeks
later a drone attack killed his 16 year
old son and his 17 year old cousin in
Yemen and that the US government refused
is to even account for what it did there
or describe what principles if you were
to talk about those things and the other
radical secrecy doctrines the Bush
administration use you would have 50
percent of the room the ones identified
self-identified as Republicans
supporting it cheering for it justifying
it apologizing for it and being happy
with it but 50 percent of the room the
ones self-identified as Democrats would
be feigning anger over it they'd be
objecting to it as shredding the
Constitution and right-wing radicalism
and all of this if you were to take that
same exact group of people and put them
in a room like this now and talk about
those same exact things that I just
described you would now have 90 percent
of the room cheering for it and
supporting it or at least justifying it
in mitigating it the way not you glacis
from that post did or at least
acquiescing to it maybe 10 percent of
the room continuing to be angry about it
because they were actually angry about
its being done the first time around and
not pretending to be angry
opportunistically for partisan gain and
this has really changed the way these
issues are discussed the fact that now
it's not just the Republican party
standing for this form of lawlessness
but that it's become under President
Obama bipartisan consensus which means
it's removed from political debate it is
hardly controversial any longer and it's
entrenched as orthodoxy in American
political life for at least a generation
there's Jack Balkan who's a yellow
professor has talked about how what when
one party objects to a policy and the
other opposes it or supports it what
happens when the other party gets into
office and starts continuing it it
becomes no longer a controversial policy
it becomes American consensus and
indoors without much challenge for at
least a generation that is what has
happened to these policies of
lawlessness and wild periods of
executive power and the right of the
American President to target anyone for
violence or interrogation or
incarceration without any oversight it
has now taken on the face of both
parties and is therefore likely
normalized for a very long time and to
me that's one of the most significant
legacies of the Obama presidency so with
that I think it's a good time to take
questions I think the mechanics were
described at the start I didn't hear it
so
well rely on you to first thanks to our
speakers
we have about 15-20 minutes for
questions so just head down to this mic
and try to keep your questions brief so
we can get to as many as you as possible
Thanks
so how do you feel after all these years
are seeing and all that you've done
seeing what's happened to our country
that yes - well to you professor Chomsky
first I've had more years
well actually it's it's it's pretty bad
but we should recognize that it's not
really all that new go back to the the
day the modern conception of
international law was pretty well
founded right after the Second World War
the Nuremberg Tribunal chartered the
United Nations and so on what so what
was the position of the United States
then well the United States was
instrumental in setting up the World
Court in International Court of Justice
but at once the United States declared
that it is not subject to any charges
based on international treaties meaning
the UN Charter the Charter the
Organization of American States or
others and in fact that actually came to
the court it came to the court during
the Reagan years when the government of
Nicaragua brought a charges against the
United States for essentially war
against Nicaragua or international
terrorism if you want to lower the
charge the Nicaraguan case was presented
by a distinguished Harvard Law School
professor most of it was thrown out and
it was thrown out because the case
appealed to the core principles of
entered modern international law UN
Charter OAS and so on so in fact when
the case was finally you know judged it
was restricted to very narrow grounds
bilateral u.s. Nicaraguan treaty and
what's called
a common international law was generally
understood even on that narrow basis the
US was accused of unlawful use of force
which means terrorism and lay language
and ordered to pay substantial
reparations well how did the bipartisan
Congress react by increasing aid to the
Contras increasing the actions just
condemned this criminal meanwhile The
New York Times for example dismissed the
court as a hostile for a proof that it's
a hostile and therefore insignificant
hostile forum because it made charges
against the US a couple of years earlier
the same Times and other commentators
were praising the court because it
supported the u.s. in a charge against
Iran well that's in fact the United
States went on to veto I think two
Security Council resolutions which
called on all states to observe
international law well all that passed
with virtually no comment almost nobody
knows about this except maybe some
specialists and it goes beyond in 1948
the United Nations passed a genocide
condemnation of genocide genocide major
crime forty years later the United
States ratified it but with the
reservation inapplicable to the United
States and that came to the courts two
couple years later Yugoslavia brought
charges against NATO for bombing and
among the charges was a reference to
genocide the United States
representative appealed to the court and
said that the United States would
withdraw for the proceedings because the
United States was formally entitled to
commit genocide which is true by this
reservation and the court accepted that
correctly the court rules are that they
can't try bring him into trial unless
they agree to the proceedings so the
United States was excluded
from the charges the rest of the NATO
powers weren't that was reported but
with no comment if we declare that we
are entitled to carry out genocide fine
then we're entitled to carry out
genocide now these things are pretty
deep it's probably true that bush broke
let's take even the torture charges if
you look carefully it's not so clear
that Bush was in serious violation of US
law when they carried out torture at
Guantanamo or at Abu Ghraib because the
u.s. never really signed the torture
convention it was rewritten by the
Senate to exclude certain categories of
torture and if you look at those
categories they are the categories that
the CIA carries out the CIA back in the
50s basing themselves on KGB manuals and
so on a redefined tortured to allow
what's called mental torture you know
the kind that doesn't leave marks so for
example actually even waterboarding so
you know take a Bradley Manning and
solitary confinement of course torture
very reasonable means but not by US law
and that was then signed into
legislation under Clinton so what's
called torture here is a very narrow
category and a good deal of the torture
that the u.s. carries out is actually
legal under US law well you know this is
discussed by specialists in
constitutional law and central Evans and
and others but almost nobody knows about
it
well you know these are things everyone
ought to know that yep okay I wanted to
ask you about two implications or
suggestions that I drew from your book
the first is the it excuse me um the
there's really the unmistakable
conclusion that that our officials you
know judges politicians won't or can't
which is more scary hold powerful
a powerful criminal behavior accountable
even in the most egregious examples such
as torture and this the possibility that
the cognitive dissonance that this
raises in our officials that they're not
you know the constant awareness that
they're not fulfilling their role as
officials may be driving this need to
sort of scapegoat to find the most
vulnerable the mo the least politically
powerful for the most trivial offenses
accountable so to be able to demonstrate
okay look we are holding we're holding a
lot of people accountable they're just
not holding you know accountable
according to law so it's this kind of
charade of judicious nough sort of
passes for lawfulness and this kind of
vigorousness behind it that maybe you
know not this knowledge of this
imbalance may be driving this kind of in
perpetuating the imbalance and then the
second implication was that when our
when our officials give up on law
enforcement as their role that perhaps
law breaking greater greater extremes of
law breaking becomes a means of
expressing power so that yes you know
our financial system engages in
widespread fraud but only the president
can violate the Constitution yeah those
are both interesting and important point
you know it is true that law and order
basically tends to mean get drug dealers
off the corner who are smelling selling
salt small quantities of drugs to to
other adults who want to buy them and of
course that has all kinds of
implications I mean the drug war is
incredibly racist it has incredibly
disproportionate effects on the poor and
yet at the same time or or law and order
means and the rule of law means you know
pepper spraying protesters and putting
them into prison for peacefully
assembling at the same time that the
police are protecting the criminals on
Wall Street who destroyed the economy
and committed fraud on an
incomprehensible scale so I think you're
right that essentially these kind of
petty transgressions that are punished
so harshly is a way of obscuring the
fact that the most significant criminals
the most consequential crimes are are
shielded and that the the biggest
criminals are allowed
to continue to run rampant with their
criminality on the other point about as
a way of expressing power you know one
of the fascinating things about this
whole idea of look for not backwards and
the like is that at the same time the
very same administration that has
invoked this Orwellian slogan as a means
of saying that we shouldn't look to
political crimes of the Bush era on has
waged the most the harshest and the most
unprecedented war on whistleblowers
people who have leaked what
unquestionably is evidence of serious
wrongdoing so for example the NSA
scandal that revealed that the Bush
administration was spying on American
citizens without the law without the
warrants that the criminal law said is
required and that the law calls a felony
if you do the only person to suffer any
consequences from that scandal is
someone named Thomas Tamm who was a
mid-level Department of Justice lawyer
who found out the Bush administration
was doing this in one day called Eric
Lichtblau at the New York Times to tell
him that this was going on he was he was
a grand jury was convened he was
continuously subpoenaed he lost his job
he couldn't afford lawyers he went
bankrupt and became had Syria's
emotional and psychological problems as
a result of that persecution all of the
people who broke the law have been
completely shielded they went on to
write books and get very rich only the
person who exposed it has been subjected
to any form of sanction and and
punishment that absolutely is about
expressing power and saying that you
know if you expose any of the things
that we're doing that are criminal and
wrong you will be the one who will be
punished
using the dressings of law to do it
while we simultaneously shield ourselves
hi and I hope you both have time to
answer this but first professor Chomsky
and I came down from occupy Burlington
Vermont today to be here and I'm really
inspired by the number of people that
have risen up to protest the bullying as
you put it of American elites in many
respects through the Occupy movement do
you think that the Occupy movement has
the potential to revolutionize
revolutionize the system to the point
that we can topple the power that has so
corrupted the rule of law what do you
think the movement will need to achieve
in order to achieve and overcome in
order to do this that's for me for me
yeah well I mean I think the Occupy
movements which are now all over the
country in fact all over the world
are a very exciting development in fact
inspiring a lot of ways and really
unprecedented I don't know of anything
quite like them in the past which is
make sense this is an unprecedented
period in many ways what can they
achieve they've already achieved a lot I
think they've put things they've shifted
the range of discussion which is quite
important they've at the very least are
laying down a legacy from which you can
move on there are short-term things that
they might be able to achieve which are
quite urgent so to take one in just a
couple of weeks the deficit Commission
is due to reach its decision which will
probably be stalemate but whether it
reaches a decision or stalemates it's a
real dagger pointed at the heart of the
country either way because if it doesn't
reach a decision you go into kind of an
automatic trap that's been set up which
is aimed at doing exactly the opposite
of what Americans
so rather striking effect you take a
look at polls
first of all large majority the people
don't think that the deficit is the
problem anyway and they're right the
problems joblessness there shouldn't be
a deficit Commission but even if you
keep to this minor question of the
deficit very large majorities have a
solution tax the super-rich bring taxes
back to what they once wore were during
our period of rapid growth in fact so
tax the super-rich and preserve benefits
even Tea Party supporters that take that
position that support protect the
benefits which are not great but are
crucial for people well the Commission
if it reaches a decision or the
automatic process if it doesn't reach a
decision are going to do just the
opposite they'll cut away at the limited
benefits incidently ignoring the reason
why they're a fiscal problem Social
Security is not a problem at all that's
just thrown in in order to try to
destroy it
Medicare is a problem because it works
through the privatized unregulated were
virtually unregulated insurance based
health care system is a complete
international scandal the US had a
health care system like other industrial
countries there wouldn't be any deficit
effect would be a surplus but that that
can't even be discussed because the
financial institutions are against it
and this goes back to things that Glen
outlines very well in his book the but
that's coming right away and it's
possible it's a long shot but if the
Occupy movements get enough kind of
force and energy and influence they
might do something about this short-term
problem now that's very far from
revolutionizing the society when you
talk about deeper problems more
long-term ones it has to be understood
and I think is that you don't get these
things overnight take say the civil
rights movement that really began in a
militant form in the nineteen
30s was years of struggle before it even
you know reached the possibility where
he could discuss it finally thanks to
very courageous activities students
sitting at at lunch counters the Freedom
Riders and all sorts of other things it
was possible to get to the point where
Martin Luther King a great figure and
modern life was able to give a talk I
have a dream talk and some gains were
one they shouldn't be underestimated
the South is a different place from what
it was and in fact as long let's take
people right around here wasn't as long
as civil rights movement was aimed at
racist Alabama sheriff's a lot of
support for it as soon as King began to
move on to opposition of the Vietnam War
and class issues remember that when he
was killed he was on his way to organize
a poor people's movement and he was
killed during a sound state in
supporting a sound well it's supporting
sanitation strike since he moved on to
those he was dismissed when you listen
to the adulation on Martin Luther King
Day you hear about the racist alabama
sheriffs well gains were won after many
years of hard struggle there's a long
way to go the criminalization that Glenn
talked about is basically kind of
reinstituting what was done in the write
up not long after the civil war
criminalizing black life and pretty much
restoring the conditions that existed so
there's a long way to go and that's one
of the successful movements and it's
true of other things too there can be
very significant gains in the long term
really revolutionary gains but they're
not going to come quickly and the main
task of the Occupy movement in
opinion is to make use of the quite
remarkable network of associations and
linkages and mutual support and building
spontaneous building of communities make
use of all of that to turn it into
something that will be long lasting and
enduring and will face the inevitable
failures and go on to overcome which is
a hard long course to follow we have
just two or three more minutes and two
more questions to go so thanks I'd be
interested what both of you think about
this taboo subject the US Attorney's
scandal the bogus acorn scandal the
current red redistricting efforts the
making photo ID requirements the making
the assault on unions in an early voting
and registration all seem part of a
concentrated war on the right to vote so
first of all given that these people
seemed to say to anything in pursuit of
their agenda what is the likelihood that
having highly hackable easily often
failing machines that they own and
operate with zero citizen oversight
would not be part of their strategy and
you have any advice for what I can do to
get this subject on the radar of my hero
Glenn Greenwald I guess you just forced
it on my radar because I'm about to
address it but you know I think just
conceptually and I will address the
specific question in a second but you
know it raises the question about
whether or not significant economic and
wealth inequality can coexist with rough
political equality or whether or not
once there's a small faction that can
gain so much power through its wealth
then political equality or democratic
institutions cannot possibly resist it
any longer or remain invulnerable to it
and there are ways and you know even the
founders talked about this the problem
that if you're going to allow wealth and
income inequality that there's the
danger that it can become
so concentrated that it will infect
political and legal institutions as well
where it's not supposed to make a
difference and yet we've seen periods of
time in American history where there's
been lots of wealth and income
inequality and yet at the same time
political and democratic institutions
have been able to act fairly
meaningfully against the most powerful
oligarchs you know Standard Oil and and
and JP Morgan were broken up Franklin
Roosevelt was able to create lots of
redistributive and social programs lots
of social progress of the kind that
Professor Chomsky was just describing so
you can it's been empirically proven
that you can have significant wealth and
income inequality at the same time
political equality that's contingent
upon subjecting those who are the most
wealthy the wealthiest and the most
politically powerful to the same rules
and limitations to which the rest of us
are bound in in which we democratically
impose on them and once that starts not
to happen that's when you get the kind
of corruption that seeps into all the
other institutions as far as control
over the voting machines and the like
you know the all political processes are
subjected to corruption and coercion and
the like I haven't seen evidence that
there's systematic fraud on the part of
in terms of our electoral process that
comes from voting machine control and at
the same time I'm not particularly
convinced that there's anyone who has
such an overwhelming interest since both
parties seem to serve the same interest
anyway I'm not really sure who would be
motivated to care enough about about
that other than the two parties
themselves but you know certainly
there's instances where there's
irregularities but I think the more
important danger is the one that you
talked about which is efforts to start
restricting the right to vote more to
make sure sort of return to the poll tax
era where people who have certain
political views or have huge impediments
thrown in the way and that to me is just
part and parcel of the generalized trend
of using what is supposed to be law and
political equality to achieve exactly
the opposite last question here and then
we can
hi all the hassle in trying to get me to
ask this question is reflective of how
my civil rights and the civil rights of
all the people who can't be here with
people with disabilities are violated by
the elite of Cambridge who also exempt
themselves from the basic civil rights
of access for 20 years I've had the
right to full free and front door access
every building in the country but the
elite of Cambridge and the good people
of Cambridge you support them exempt
this elite by using the term historic
which is an ideological term meaning
looks good and keeps property values up
and by that process there is a special
entrance for me that I got to go in in
which the elevator fell an inch and a
half when I got in when we got to the
top of the elevator we ran into a
handcart and boxes blocking my way out
and then the door into the auditorium
was locked and then when I came in
finally after knocking to get in no one
knew what to do with me or where to put
me so I I call this bullying it's it's
really a constant ongoing humiliation
now of course the burden that would be
placed on the bridle by making it fully
accessible through the front entrance
would cost a lot but maybe that money is
meanwhile being used to put the
torturing brick sidewalks on my way to
try to get to the front entrance which
everyone knows tortures people with
disabilities and anyone pushing any
wheels and yet they're all over this
area because the elite of exempted
themselves right in front of everyone
and unfortunately you end up
participating in a glen by coming to an
event where people can't get to were
bullied all the time i was in the street
most of the way on the way to get here
and i hope that in the future that you
would not speak in a place that didn't
have every single person who could come
in come in the front door because coming
in the front door used to be something
that was seen as a civil right in itself
thank you very much
yeah so I you know obviously I wasn't
aware of this building ever before
there's laws that require reasonable
steps to be taken to provide access to
people who are disabled I've litigated
those cases before on behalf people who
are disabled whether there's issues
around historic designations on the like
is something I'm just not aware of them
I'm pre shuttup of your bringing it to
my attention though and and to the
attention of everyone here something
I'll certainly give some thought to if I
can just add a word that I think the
complaint quite legitimate but it also
bears on the preceding question of can
we do anything about it and the answer
is yes we can it's very different from
what it was 40 years ago and those
changes which have are part of a part of
the general civilizing of the country in
many ways that has traces back to many
things but in particular to the activism
of the 60s and it's aftermath a large
part of the civilizing effect of the 60s
actually began later
so the feminist movement for example has
had a huge change the support for access
of disabled people that's all pretty
much post 60s and it shows what can be
achieved by popular engagement a
recognition of serious issues pressure
to do something about them and progress
and progress still has big gaps but we
shouldn't overlook the fact two facts
one that there has been progress and two
that that progress has not been a gift
from above but has been achieved through
popular engagement often struggle and
that's a lesson for the future
for more information about Glenn
Greenwald visit salon.com / writer /
Glenn underscore Greenwald